Semi open stands
has become the most important stands in the modern game
because balls are jumping higher,
and semi open still allows you to hit through the ball
enough to put pressure on your opponent
while dealing with these higher bouncing shots.
And at the same time,
club players
really struggle with getting into this semi open stance.
So here's a tip from OTI instructor
Ian Meyer to help with that semi open stance.
This is a key position.
Look at me from this side
and then look at me from this side.
You can clearly see this foot is behind this foot.
That position is very challenging for people.
Here's a quick tip you can use.
Think about when you practice.
Go back, front, back.
Try this thing where you use the baseline
and bring this foot back behind the line.
This footsteps in front of the line
and this footsteps behind the line again.
So there's a three step sequence.
So it's Cha, Cha,
Cha. And there
I'm in the perfect semi open stance to make the shot.